on the bound for the padres is rhys
skinner reece can he recall today as the
29th man in the second game for today
started the suspended game of the
originally scheduled doubleheader that
was back in july 21st well the ball died
down there in a double for ozzy
riley shoots one to right field that's
down for a hit and the braves are going
to take a one-nothing lead that's how
you answer
suspended game disappointment
back-to-back two-out hits both of them
opposite field and riley's got 98 runs
batted in it's one to nothing max
freight has been dominant he's a former
padre pick and you know he'd love to
beat the team that drafted him jake
cronin worth playing first base for the
padres
one taps slowly right to dansby he'll
step on the pillow and free gets a
double play shut down inning freedom the
braves off to a great start in a huge
game
rosario's at second base and dansby
swanson
dansby shoots one to right field that's
pretty deep at the wall myers leaping
try it's gone
opposite field home run for dansby
swanson
that's number 27
and the braves lead three to nothing
running back across the outside of pitch
and he goes apple taco
man
and max free to work against manny
machado
off the end of the bat and right at
freddie freeman max will take that
another ground ball out everything on
the turf and dirt for freed in the first
inning and a third tonight only hitting
264 as a padre but he's been a tough out
swaying and amiss what a pitch from
freed took a little off at 87 and got
him to whiff one strikeout for max
rivas called up from el paso today
and this one chopped on the ground
dansby will flip to ozzie and max free
continues his mastery five ground ball
outs one strikeout and that's freddy
freeman leads it off with ozzy albee's
and austin reilly to follow this is the
teeth of the braves order in short right
and it's going right to him in short
right
his throw in time to get freddie freeman
sky to center grisham going back
pedaling to make the catch
two down two and two here's the pitch
and duval takes on the inside corner
strike three call
95 mile an hour paint from reece kinnear
his first strike out of the night and
his first scoreless inning of the night
bridge lead three nothing bottom of the
third inning max freed is churning up
ground balls he's gotten five of them so
far in his first two innings and max
frieda's rolling another ground ball
right back to the mound he is such a
good fielder
and that's six ground ball outs
well you can't spell caneer without a k
freight has two strikeouts fam bounced
out his first time up 2-2
ground ball out to ozzy taking on two
big hops he gathers and throws and
that's a one two three inning
fernando to lead it off in the bottom of
the fourth inning swings at the 2-1 and
that's a fair ball
down the right field line so they're
over to play it is tatisse
into second base with the stand up
double to begin the bottom of the fourth
inning
cronin worth hitting to a double play
his first time up
what a pitch from freidy strikes out
cronenworth third strikeout for freed
one-on-one out machado bounced out to
freddie freeman in the second inning the
pitch
and him reaching for the breaking ball
that'll get the runner to third
but that's another ground ball out for
max fried he has eight of them
one ball no strikes runner at third
three nothing we're in the padres fourth
inning
roll to the left side dansby's got it
throws on the run stretch and they got
him what a play
wow yeah you're right max freed wow
indeed
dansby has hit a homer he just saved a
run with a great play he robs myers with
riley darting in front a perfect
striking stretch bottom of the fifth
inning for the padres
frazier rivas and grisham do up and a
soft line drive hit out towards second
ozzie had to wait for it he's got it one
pitch one away
webster rivas bounced into a force play
to end the padres second
another ground ball dansby's got a
charge gloves grabs catcher running took
his time two out
tenth ground ball out
and he hits it the other way in the air
but that's going to be playable for
rosario max freed set down six in a row
he preserves a three nothing lead after
five pitch the strikeout of all these
aborted first here's austin riley
taking off his albies and he is safe at
second base stolen base and striking out
was riley but a hit means a run for
duval who's old for two tonight 1-0
pitch
bouncing ball that's going to sneak
through for a base hit ozzy around third
duval does it again it's four-nothing
atlanta
so he's at the top of his game so far on
the road trip
there's some contact but right to ozzie
high throw but freeman stretches out
from one native of curacao to another
profar is retired you've got fam then
tatis four nothing atlanta
blew him away
four strikeouts for max freed
in the air
right field solaire's got it freed has
six in the books he's thrown 64 pitches
he set down eight straight he has set
down nine consecutive hitters and in the
home seventh cronenworth machado and
mariznick are coming up
fly ball
center field but plenty of room
one out and here's machado he's hit the
ball on the ground twice
11 ground ball outs for max four
strikeouts
roughly speaking is another tapper back
to the mount another ground ball out
is going to be quite the battle and a
lot of fun
in the air
left field rosario plenty of room it's
12 up 12 down for max freed he's through
seven with a shutout he's given up three
hits when you average ten pitches per
inning in a big league game against an
offense like this you are at the top of
your craft
popped up this one in play right at the
mound and dansby in on the grass puts
that away and freed's retired 13 in a
row
on the ground freddie freeman a backhand
perfect feed from the gold glover
another ground ball out that's 13 of
them he set down 14 straight three head
has been
solid as steel and he's going to get
another ground ball out with a good
throw he's got it 14 ground ball outs
eight shutout innings and he enjoys a
four nothing lead 14 ground ball outs
he's retired the last 15 padres in order
as he heads to the ninth inning he'll
have profar a pinch hitter and then
tatisse first the 2-2 pitch
on the ground and right to riley a
one-hop bullet there's out number one 16
up 16 down 15 ground ball outs so it is
hosmer in the ninth inning
i'm getting another ground ball ozzy's
got it pegged to first
17 up 17 down 16 ground outs for freed
braves fans chopping and chanting with
one out to get
on the ground riley's got it krohoff
fires high to first and that's your ball
game a masterpiece from max freed
a complete game shutout his second of
this season